but i remember i was speaking to my
friend
and he was like yeah do you ever just
feel awkward when sex scenes come on
when you're with your friends and i'm
like no
no i'm like i'm like no not at all when
you're with your friends and stuff like
what no yeah why would i feel awkward
with the sex in my mates like then it
was just weird isn't it i'm like no i
don't think i've ever watched the sex
scene with my mates now i think about it
is that like a thing you have to like
check off i don't know
you never watched a film with your
friends that has a sex scene in it i'm
trying to think i think i've watched
like funny porno plots with my friends
like fake taxi with my friends i've just
watched porn with my friends
i think i think i have watched i have
been like let's watch this funny porno
you know oh yeah of course yeah yeah i
don't think i've ever gone through that
no that's like my favorite past times
like watching cursed porn with my
friends
i had a friend as well i was like you
can watch straight uh normal movies with
straight sex in it okay but he couldn't
watch not normal movies with gay sex
scenes in it with his friends who's just
super uncomfortable
that's just a bit of macho insecurity
yeah
that sounds a bit insecure
i don't know man the sound sounds like
you're a little insecure and he's like
no no no i just don't like it i'm like
why don't you like it and then he's like
i'm not homophobic i'm like
i don't know
i think there's nothing manlier than
being able to sit there and enjoy that
you know come on man what's wrong you
know it's just blokes hanging out i know
is these like lads lads i i feel like
yeah that happens a lot of guys like
that in the uk though you know there's
always there's always one guy like that
i feel in every guy i i feel like
lad's culture is definitely like a thing
in the uk which is like kind of i'll
save in australia yeah yeah is do you do
you guys have labs culture in australia
your friends who would be like that if
you try if you're oh yeah absolutely
like you know like because i went to a
boys school as well so it was even more
so where it's like just macho and
security everywhere where you know you'd
be out yeah it's kind of school it's
kind of toxic yeah yeah
i didn't know and they'd just be like
you know a girl from like you know a
nearby girl school or whatever yeah yeah
oh you you oh you should totally smash
her bro you should totally smash it i'm
just like i'm not you know i i try to be
confrontational because they're your
friends right but i also try and i'm not
going to sit there and be like dude
that's pretty you know that's pretty not
okay that's just
pretty it's pretty [ __ ]
i've had arguments with my friends about
it as well or i'll just be like yeah
that's uh that's kind of homophobic i
don't actually realize it is but that is
homophobia yeah yeah exactly why do you
think because we spend so much time on
the internet that we've just had like
more awareness about this kind of
culture and stuff i think so because you
know a lot of my friends would never be
like they're not
i don't think they would ever be like i
hate gay people or anything like that
right but also you have to understand
where that comes from if you if there's
something where you can watch a normal
sex scene but you can't watch a gay sex
scene yeah like why is that like what's
going on there like
if you're a normal person surely who
doesn't give a [ __ ] you'd have no
problem to either right yeah you know
maybe you would find one harder than the
other but surely you wouldn't have a
problem right yeah i don't know if this
is too much for trash taste viewers
i mean like just because you're okay
with watching a sexy doesn't mean you
need to be like into it no that's what i
like that's what i'm saying
that's what i was saying
i was trying to feel like i was like
yeah you don't have to actively dislike
it like but like you don't have to like
turn it off or like go in the other room
yeah you know what i mean like
you can just sit there and be like all
right it's not for me but i'm not going
to be disgusted by it it's part of the
story right yeah it's like this is what
it is yeah that's what i was saying i
was like you know if it's part of the
plot it's what it is man like they're
like oh it's just kind of weird isn't it
i'm like i'm like is it weird explain
how it's weird don't watch brokeback
mountain if that's the case
that's literally what that movie is
about i was like i was like that's the
problem though
you think it's weird like it's not like
it's like it's not it's not weird that
people [ __ ] yeah
i think i think the problem is that it's
just a lot of the times especially like
in lads culture people just have never
thought about this too deeply because
that's that's like they have these they
yeah i'm not saying that someone is yeah
i totally agree with you go ahead yeah
no because like
this this is what i feel every time i go
back to my hometown and i see some like
my hometown friends who like i i very
much grew up in like lads culture
hanging out with like let's let's land
and they still like [ __ ] go to you
know go every every [ __ ] summer go to
ibiza and you know try to smash as many
birds as possible it's you know that
that kind of that's what it is that's
kind of like lads culture and i'm just
like
as i've grown older i'm just like this
is a kind of a toxic mindset in a lot of
ways you know it's uh it's it's very
much
uh because i think the problem is that
they don't really talk about it they
don't really talk about their don't
really talk about their feelings or like
really think about things too deeply
because yeah that's not a loud thing
it's considered weak yeah that's
considered weak yeah you're not an alpha
male if you talk about your feelings and
[ __ ] and also you know they don't really
have conversations like this yeah they
don't talk about it so normally when
i've when it's been saying that i've
spoken about people it's like
especially in like where i'm from it's
like the first person who's ever been
like no why do you feel that way about
this yeah
like
now why is it that it makes you
uncomfortable you know what i mean like
yeah so what do you mean by that yeah
yeah yeah it's not on that and i was
just like and then you know and i've had
like confrontations about it because
it's like yeah they get very defensive
about it because yeah like they feel
like oh [ __ ] wait is he trying to say
that i'm i'm in the wrong for feeling
this way yeah yeah and it's like well no
i'm not trying to but it's like why are
you feeling that way maybe i think maybe
you just want to have a discussion about
it maybe maybe oh like maybe look at
like what's going on
it's funny because like some of the most
kind of insecure
feeli uh people i've ever met are like
the uh like some of the like biggest
lads i've ever seen like the prop like
jim bros who
sometimes it's it's insecurity sometimes
it's it's uh it toxic masculinity
sometimes homophobia it's like it's
whatever it is it's like get to the core
of it if that's what's bothering you you
can't watch brokeback mountain without
being disgusted
it's a great movie
all i'm saying is if you're a guy don't
be afraid to talk about your feelings
with other guys i feel like i feel like
i didn't have that when i was growing up
because i thought i thought that it was
the mentality where if i did this with
my bros then i was the weak one you know
that's that's that's not what that's not
what bros do to each other yeah you know
and i i wouldn't say we're like sjw or
anything like that i just i don't know i
just don't
don't want to discriminate
exactly why should you you know i don't
know exactly my personal opinion i'm
sure that i'm i'm no doubt there's some
viewers of trash taste i can't believe
this they've spoken about this issue and
stuff but i mean that's i mean it's a
sensitive time
stuff that i would talk about yeah but i
mean there's some things that are
sensitive and there's some things where
i'm like no that's just straight up
wrong yeah
of course yeah i mean there's you know
there's some things where i'm just like
i i think we i think we should talk
about this and i think you know it's i
think
it's not toxic at all to at least start
a conversation because i think a lot of
a lot of the times a lot of people just
haven't really never really put any
thought into it and they correctly
don't yeah they grew up in a culture
they grew up in a lifestyle and that has
just never
put them in a position that challenges
the way they think yeah and if someone
does feel uncomfortable with us talking
about this topic or hearing that idea
makes you uncomfortable i would say just
like don't get angry about it don't
don't you know react to it just think
like all right just turn off trash taste
go watch no no no
just think why does it like why does it
get you angry like what about it like if
that's like a whole religious thing all
right fine that's that's that's your
problem about like i don't know like
yeah i cuz like i just feel like it's
it's better now for at least people who
are like i guess on the internet and
especially on social media because
people are talking about this more often
yeah which is good but i still like
they're they're
you forget sometimes that
we are not i i don't even know if we're
the majority you know because you like
every time i go home i don't know
about it it's hard to tell because we're
i'm like so ingrained in obviously our
jobs are surrounded with the internet
and surrounded with you know people who
think like me that i it's weird whenever
you go to like go back home see family
see friends from back home and you're
just like wow everyone thinks exactly
the same everyone has not changed much
at all because they just there's no one
in their community or in this group of
friends that are exposed to the same
thing as we are so yeah no totally yeah
because obviously on my channel like
very pro-lgbtq but like
obviously going back home it's not a
thing that's spoken about much it is
kind of it depends who you ask really i
think now more than before definitely
yeah with how the world's just changing
right yeah my parents are pretty good
with it i i always try to educate when i
can try and tell them about it yeah like
i would like to think most of the time
it is just pure ignorance and oh totally
yeah especially if in small towns yeah
you know obviously not everyone is on
the internet all the time everyone's in
a big city you've surrounded me so it's
you know a lot of the time they just
don't come across it they're just like
oh it's a that guy's very funny on tv
and he's gay
really
that's what it's what my parents are
like they're like you know he's gay
who's gay
thanks man they're cool that's like
that's like a thing
but i mean you know it's uh
it's it's ever i mean it's everywhere
right now so it's like it's yeah yeah i
just ironed him it's uh it sucks that
it's one of those things that it even
has to be somewhat controversial
to talk about right and we've already
spoke about trash taste i'm sure that
some people will be alienated by it but
it sucks that even has to be something
that alienates people yeah you know when
it's defect people are gay get over it
we just like broke back man
that's a great [ __ ] graveyard that's
a [ __ ] awesome movie
trash tastes broke back mountain
watching
keith ledger jake gyllenhaal [ __ ]
amazing job